Okay, Simon has an interesting question.
He says, what do you think about e-comm
with the digital asset approach?
Can he do it?
Guys, my answer to this is whether you're asking me
about pull barns, whether you're asking me
about assisted living leads,
whether you're asking me about whatever,
if you use this strategy, which is getting paid traffic
or organic traffic to a landing page or to a website,
you are going to get leads or conversions.
Because if you're selling a product,
the same principles apply.
However, the thing that makes this model so special
is the fact that we can use a generic website.
And if, let's say our client starts to get sideways on us,
they start to get a little funny, they start to complain,
we can sell those leads to somebody else.
So if you do e-comm, let's say you go to a company
and they're like, hey, I want you to sell
these water filters for us, right?
And you're doing all this SEO for these water filters.
That's great, but first of all, first and foremost,
you're probably gonna be doing SEO on like a national level,
which makes it very difficult.
It's gonna be much more difficult to get SEO,
to rank using SEO, to get organic rankings.
The other thing, guys, is that company's kind of gonna
have you buy the balls, right?
Because if you're advertising their products
and you're using their branding or their location
or their specific keywords that they wanna target,
what happens if they don't wanna buy leads anymore?
So you have to remember that one of the best parts
about this business model is the ability
to have complete control over our assets
and not have to be at the mercy of anybody.
And this kind of defeats the purpose of it.
So could it work?
Yes.
Do I recommend it?
No.
If it's your own brand and it's your own e-comm products,
your own e-comm store, your own products,
then okay, fine, use the SEO principles
in the second half of the training
to get your website ranked.
But to do it for somebody else,
I don't think it's the move.